IAN FETTE: Thank you all very
much for coming to the Google
Chrome Fireside Chat.
My name's Ian Fette.
I am a product manager on
Google Chrome, and I'd like
to introduce everyone
else up here on stage.
We've got Alex Russell, one at
the software engineers on the
Google Chrome team, Brian
Rakowski, director of Product
Management for Google Chrome,
and Erik Kay, also a
software engineer on the
Google Chrome team.
I'd think we'd like to keep
this sort of informal.
I'm a big fan of just
Q&A style sessions.
So there's a mike in the
middle of the room.
If you have any questions for
the panel, or for any of us,
please come up to the mike
in the middle of the
room and ask away.
00:01:03,82 --> 00:01:03,06
[UNINTELLIGIBLE QUESTION]
IAN FETTE:
Will we accept shouted
questions from the sardines
in the middle of rows?
Yes, but if someone is at the
mike, they will get priority.
That was easy, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm at the mike.
I'm gonna try and phrase this
statement as a question.
Today you announced the
Google Chrome App Store.
In the same conversation,
almost the same breath as
talking about all the openness
and that, can you connect
those two in an open way?
ERIK KAY: Sure.
I'll take a stab at this.
So think about the web
apps that are gonna
be on the web store.
They're really just web apps.
They're the same web apps.
The only difference is that
we're providing a little bit of
glue, a little bit of metadata
to describe those apps.
So existing web app runs on any
modern browser, tack on a
little bit of metadata that
allows it to run a little bit
nicer in the browser, that
allows the listing to show up
in the store, that's all.
AUDIENCE: When I buy an app,
where does the permission model
key into that and how does it
-- like is that -- is it
locking it into Chrome or if
I'm running Chrome and
I'm also running--
ERIK KAY: No, definitely not.
AUDIENCE: --Safari, I could
also run the same app?
ERIK KAY: So, if you want to
sell web apps, the thing that
you're using there will be
our backend license server.
So at that point, this is again
web app talking to web server,
and so that technology should
run, you know, on any browser.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
IAN FETTE: Open
mike at the floor.
Please step on up.
Don't be shy.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE QUESTION]
ERIK KAY: Sure.
Let me repeat the
question since it was
a shouted question.
The question is, well, if you
went to check it out today, you
can only try it out on Windows,
and that kind of sucks for
everybody using Mac or Linux,
and yes, we're sorry.
So let me give you a little
bit of rationale for
why it is this way.
You know, Chrome, being an
open-source project is
a blessing and a curse.
So the blessing part of that is
that from your guys
perspective, hopefully, is that
you get to see stuff
really early on.
We don't really get to keep
secrets for very long because
anyone-- we have reporters who
are literally monitoring
are source checkins.
So basically, you know, people
are going to figure this out
before too long here anyway.
So what you're catching us is
in the stage where we're still
iterating on the UI and still
trying to make decisions.
Now typically in the
development cycle, we do our
prototyping on one platform,
and it depends on the team,
depends on what they're doing
most of their development on.
But since we're making lots of
changes and lots of stuff, it
doesn't make sense to do that
three times until we're a
little bit closer to being
for sure this is it.
We do have some early
work happening on Mac.
I think we're not that far away
from being able to have people
play with it on Mac, but it
just doesn't make sense for
us to do it all together.
But our plan is to have a
developer preview for all
platforms later this summer.
So anyway, you can hear
more details about
some of this stuff.
There's a session tomorrow
going into more detail.
IAN FETTE: Next question.
AUDIENCE: I was noticing that
on the schedule, it says this
is a Fireside Chat with like
Google Chrome and
Chrome OS team.
Are we clear to ask
Chrome OS questions?
Can you guys answer those?
BRIAN RAKOWSKI: We actually
don't have anyone from
the Chrome OS team here.
We have people all representing
Chrome here so you're
welcome to ask questions.
We may not give you very
interesting answers.
AUDIENCE: OK, sure.
Yeah, then I'll still
ask my question.
Just first of all, what is kind
of the status of Chrome OS?
I know there's been
some -- I've heard a
little bit about it.
I haven't heard too much buzz.
I was actually kind of
expecting to hear more today,
especially with kind of the --
there's been these massive
overtones of HTML5 and the
Chrome web app store, and now
it just came from the NaCl
session with running native
code in Chrome, and
that all sounds great.
And is all that going to
be kind of incorporated
into Chrome OS?
And the other question I guess
I would have is what's kind
of the time line on that.
I know Notion Inc. is coming
out with their Adam tablet
they claim can run Chrome OS.
And I think it was Acer or Asus
who is supposed to come out
with a netbook that
can run Chrome OS.
Just what's the -- and maybe
you guys don't even know the
answer to those questions, but
just to put them out there.
BRIAN RAKOWSKI: Yeah, I
can give a quick answer.
So in terms of the progress and
the status update on Chrome
OS, the team is continuing to
make really good progress.
It's all happening in
the open source, like
the rest of Chrome.
So there's no secrets there
and everybody can check
and see what's happening.
We don't have a lot of new
things to announce right now.
We're focusing what we're
talking about on the stuff that
people can play with as
developers unless, of course,
you want to plug in to the
Chrome OS development itself in
the open-source project.
In terms of the schedule, I
think things are moving along.
We don't have any announcements
in terms of products that are
going to be shipping with
Chrome OS, but as you know,
there's lots of people who are
downloading the source,
compiling it and sticking it on
Netbook, so people are playing
with it that way, but I
certainly don't recommend
doing that as a user.
But as a developer, we're
very excited to see all
the momentum around it.
So it's still very important.
We're still chugging
along on it.
It's not forgotten or
something like that.
It's just not much to talk
about yet right now.
IAN FETTE: And part of your
question was around the
native client session,
around the web story.
We're working very hard to make
sure that everything we do in
Chrome benefits Chrome
OS and vice versa.
So you see UI concepts that are
first prototype on Chrome OS
making their way into Chrome
where it makes sense.
All the work that we're doing
in Chrome like native client,
the web store, all of
that is available, in
Chrome OS as well.
So we're trying to make sure
that innovations that happen
on either side of the product
make it all the way around
when that makes sense.
And for native client
and the web store, that
definitely makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: As an enterprise
customer for apps with about
17,000 seats, we're trying
to move away from--
ERIK KAY: Could you
step up to the mike?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, yeah.
I'm an enterprise apps customer
with about 17,000 users.
We're trying to move away from
IE6 and we'd like to take
Chrome seriously, but without
things like group policy
controls and being able to
create custom packages,
we can't really do that.
Is there anything in the works?
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah.
So there is a series of group
policy controls for Omaha,
which is the auto update
system, which will today allow
you to configure when and how
Google Chrome is updated.
So for those of you who
don't know, Google Chrome
continuously auto-updates
in the background.
So every time we push a new
revision, it's out to 90-plus
percent of the user base, you
know, in months, not years.
So you, as an administrator,
can choose to today, through
that group policy template,
configure when those updates
come down so you can lock it.
And as another potential option
for you, I work on a product
called Chrome Frame, which
allows you to run Google's
Chrome rendering
engine inside of IE6.
So in case you have
applications inside your
firewall but can't move just
yet, you may not have to run
browsers side by side.
IAN FETTE: We also have a group
of engineers that are working
on making more of the Google
Chrome settings configurable
via group policy.
Some of those you'll see start
to role out in Chrome 6.
So that's also ongoing work.
AUDIENCE: So before joining
Mozilla, I was interested in
the auto-detection of
extensions and web apps like
that on the web in
a way that's open.
Recently, there was a post on
Mozilla apps -- I don't know if
any of you caught it -- about
indexing extensions and apps.
And I was just wondering,
I would love to get
your guys' feedback.
We didn't really hear anything
from any other browser
vendors, but we're going
to start exploring it.
So do you guys think
that that's something
you'd want to pursue?
Like an HTML, sort of like, I
know there's pseudo-standards
and metatags and stuff like
that, but go that direction?
ERIK KAY: Yeah, this is
definitely something we're
exploring, and you know, I
don't think we have anything
really specific to share,
but there's sort of two
ways you can look at.
So one is discovery on the
pages that are -- directly
are the app, right?
Saying oh, I am a web app or
I have a related extension,
that sort of metadata.
The other thing, to be honest,
is that, you know, all the
different galleries and stores
that are out there actually
contribute a lot to search and
discoverability that
are out there.
AMO for Firefox gets
crawled, all of its pages.
If you know you want to look
for a Firefox extension that
does X, Y, Z, you know it's
really easy to search in any
search engine and find
it, and the same with
Chrome extensions.
But I think that -- so I think
that part is already in pretty
good shape, but I think we
should keep pushing on that,
that having curated directories
with reviews and rankings in
popularity, these are
all things that help
make search better.
But as far as discovery on the
web, we think that's important
to -- the reason why that is
important is to sort of help
people have more accidental
discoveries, connected things
to the things they typically
do, and I think there are a
number of different approaches
to that aside from just
the metadata thing.
But I don't think we have
anything concrete to
share at this stage.
IAN FETTE: The microphone
is open if anyone has
questions, or feel free
to just shout it out.
00:11:18,66 --> 00:11:18
[UNINTELLIGIBLE QUESTION]
IAN FETTE: Erik, what's
the payment mechanism
for the web store?
ERIK KAY: I'm a
popular guy today.
Well, that's a good question.
We're going to be using
Google checkout, primarily.
We're -- I think beyond that,
we don't have a lot to share.
It's something that we
understand that basically today
on the web, you can already
sell things, and so we have to
compete with what's
already out there.
So it's our intent to try to
make a really smooth experience
for developers and end users,
and so this is, you know, a
challenging thing to do for
anybody, as anybody who's
been involved in payment
systems before knows.
But we're intending to be
has broad and deep as
we can on that front.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE QUESTION]
ERIK KAY: As I said before,
you're catching us pretty
early -- I'm sorry, I should
repeat the questions.
So the question was, what's
the revshare model for
the web store, I imagine.
So you're catching us pretty
early in -- in the process here
because, you know, like I said,
the open-source nature, and
some of the concrete business
details like that, we have
ideas for it, we're working
through that, but we don't have
anything definitive
to share yet.
AUDIENCE: Hi, what challenges
do you have the developers --
as developers that we wouldn't
think you would have?
I mean, obviously, one of
them, is everyone looking
at every checking you do?
ALEX RUSSELL: We have to
write in C plus plus.
[LAUGHTER]
IAN FETTE: I think from my
perspective -- I should caveat
this -- I manage the group
that's working on all the HTML5
APIs in the web platform -- I
think a lot of people have this
notion that now that Google has
a web browser and a bunch of
web applications that it can
just sort of go off and do
whatever it wants to do, and it
turns out that things are a
lot more nuanced than that.
We work very hard to make sure
that the APIs that we develop
give a lot of power to web
application authors, not just
at Google, but across the web
as a whole, and so we have to
do a lot of work to think what
is the right API for the web,
not just for Google, but
for all web authors.
We have to think about how
does this fit in with
other web standards.
We've spent a lot of time in
standards bodies, and while we
don't constrain ourselves, we
don't require full buy-in
before we do anything,
before we innovate.
It's certainly not the case
that we just go off and do
whatever it is that we want to
do without any consideration
for web standards, web
communities, other developers.
So I think that's something
that takes a lot more time and
effort than most people would
expect, but in the long run, I
think it's well worth
it for us to do that.
ERIK KAY: So I think the thing
that maybe people who are
developers, who have developed
client code before, might
appreciate that I think is the
thing I'm probably most proud
of that the Chrome team has
done is kind of something sort
of deep and esoteric, which is
that we release from the
trunk, you know, every
week, basically.
So what that means is we're
pushing out a new client build,
you know, from, you know,
from the tip of tree.
There are no private branches.
There's no large efforts
going on that people aren't
seeing that aren't getting
pushed out immediately.
And the fact that we're having
to do that every week means
that we have a lot of
responsibility to not regress,
to not introduce new
performance regressions, to not
break compatibility for some
large number of sites, for not
really messing things up
when we add some new
experimental feature.
And for all the web developers
in the room, you're used to
this, that this is something
you have to do that
all the time.
In C
land and integrating with OS's
and all of that, this is
something that I think has
really never really been done
before, and it's partly because
of our auto-update mechanisms,
but also partly because of our
development practices and
engineering philosophy.
But as a result, it winds up
being quite challenging.
You check something, in, if you
break something, your change
will get reverted immediately.
So there's people, and
people will give you
a hard time about it.
And so you have to be very
careful, and your code has
to be very well tested
before it lands.
ALEX RUSSELL: Just to Ian's
point, just to elaborate
a little bit more.
We take that responsibility for
innovating out in front and
then cleaning up the mess, if
we don't get it right, very
seriously, and that's caused us
to do a lot of work in the last
year, particularly around
features like databases where
we tried something and it
changed the discussion
and that's great.
And we're excited about the way
people are thinking about it
now, but it does mean that we
have to go back and do a bunch
more work to make sure that
when the standard does come
down the pike, we get it right,
and we go and we do the work to
make sure that we are standards
compliant as well as
simply innovative.
IAN FETTE: And we've done that
with -- you can actually see
a number of products
that exemplify that.
For example, with Gears, we
were really out there trying to
innovate and give offline
access and offline data storage
capabilities to applications,
and it was a great thing
for Google to do.
It was a great success.
It showed that these APIs are
actually worthwhile, and now
there's a standard for how you
do it offline applications and
how you do offline data storage
and so now we're implementing
those standards.
Same thing with 3D graphics.
We put out O3D as an example
for the need for rich graphics
capabilities in the web
browser, and now we -- most of
the -- Firefox and others, are
collaborating on a spec called
WebGL to give 3D graphics
capabilities to browsers.
So we've deprecated O3D as the
product in favor of WebGL So we
are committed to standards and
to making sure that when we do
something, we do it in a way
that's good for the web.
We take in feedback from web
community to help build up a
standard and then we support
that standard going forward.
AUDIENCE: Yes, so this is
related to all of that.
One thing you didn't mention is
web sockets, and that protocol
is kind of -- by Mozilla said
they wouldn't push it at least
until there's a little bit more
standardization around,
that sort of API.
I wonder what the
status of that is.
If you guys are planning
to sort of solidify that?
Just talk about it a little?
IAN FETTE: Sure.
So I can definitely
speak to web sockets.
I can't speak to Mozilla's
shipping plans because I don't
represent Mozilla, but suffice
to say that we've had a number
of lunches over beer
with Mozilla to talk
about web sockets.
There was a lot of beer.
In terms of the web sockets,
API itself, it's somewhat
interesting in that it
started off in the
WHATWG working group.
So Hixie wrote the first draft,
recognizing the need to have
bidirectional communications
between a client
app and a server.
So for those of you who aren't
familiar with web sockets,
today you can use hanging GET
requests and a bunch of posts
to effectively have
bidirectional communication
from your web app
to the server.
This has a number
of down sides.
Namely, each time you send
something to the server,
you have to send
all of the headers.
So if you want to send a
one-character update, saying
the user just pressed
"a," that can blow
up to easily a kilobyte.
A web socket is designed to
provide a long-lived connection
that's bidirectional so either
the app or the server can send
data, and there's a small
amount of framing around that
data, but you don't have
all the headers each time.
So this work that started off
from WHATWG is now split
between WHATWG, W3C and IETF.
IETF is now contributing in
terms of the actual protocol,
the wire format, how the data
appears on the network, and
there's a lot of changes
being made right now.
At Google, since we do have
this frequent-release cycle
with Google Chrome where we're
shipping a new build every week
to the Dev channel, we are
trying to stay on the tip of
tree of that specification.
So we're in the process right
now of implementing Draft
76 for web sockets.
We're going to ship that.
We already shipped Draft 75 in
a previous version of Chrome,
and we think that web sockets
right now is at that point
where there's not enough people
using it right now that we're
worried about shipping
breaking changes.
So we are staying on the
tip of that specification
and continuing to ship
the latest version.
Obviously, we'd like to see it
solidify, but we don't see
it as a problem as of yet.
So we're going to continue to
contribute to the protocol
development and ship a
client based on the latest
version of the protocol.
AUDIENCE: So, related to that
last answer, I know that Google
has also been having some
efforts to try to speed up the
rate of communication to get
around the HTTP protocol.
This web socket solution, will
that be able to embrace that
solution that Google has been
proposing that will double the
speed, I think or so, as
has been talked about?
IAN FETTE: Yes, I believe what
you're referring to is called
Speedy, which is designed to
take HTTP and make it much
faster to load a web page
with many resources.
Speedy and web sockets are
in many ways orthogonal.
So Speedy is designed to take
an entire page with a bunch of
resources, like hundreds of
images and CSS files, and allow
that to be delivered to the
client in a much up more
efficient manner, so
much faster, primarily
targeting latency.
Web sockets is not about
loading the entire page.
Web sockets is really about
replacing the use of hanging
GETS and post requests
through that bidirectional
communication back and forth
between the web application
and the server.
So while Speedy can be used to
speed up the load of that web
application, web sockets
is designed to make the
communication of that web
application and its server more
efficient so the two are sort
of orthogonal in that respect.
ALEX RUSSELL: It is worth
noting that Speedy defines an
opening to a server that's
stateful so you do get a
bidirectional stateful
communication channel and web
socket will be able to run over
that, but that's again a
negotiation that both the
client and the server will have
to make once clients and
servers have both Speedy and
web socket implementations.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'd like to get
you guys' thoughts on WebGL.
Do you know what the status of
it is and kind of where Chrome
stands in relation to it?
IAN FETTE: So the status, we're
now shipping it in nightly
builds of Google Chrome.
I think we've turned
off the flag on that.
I'd have to double check.
You can see a lot of demos that
will actually run in a Dev
channel build of Google Chrome.
So we're definitely happy with
the progress that's being made.
We're not quite done yet, but I
think it's safe to say that
WebGL is something that we
support, that we're happy to
see continued development on,
and we will continue to develop
and support that specification.
ERIK KAY: By the way, this is
another good one to sort of
follow on to the previous --
the earlier question about
what's harder to do than
you might expect for us.
WebGL is one of those
things that sounds
really straightforward.
It's like, oh, it's just a 3D
API, you know, and my desktop
has been doing that forever,
but partly because of the
nature of Chrome's process
model and security system.
It turns out that doing 3D
graphics in a sandboxed
rendering process is quite
challenging, and especially
if we want to maintain
performance and fidelity.
You know, that's been a lot of
work to get right, and all
that's starting to come
together, and the nice thing
about that is now that we're
sort of getting all this
accelerated 3D rendering
working in the sandboxed model,
you're going to see us being
able to do more exciting
accelerated graphics and
speeding up Chrome along a
bunch of different lines that
you haven't seen us do yet.
ALEX RUSSELL: There's active
work right now, for instance,
on hardware-accelerating CSS
transforms so web-based CSS
transforms in Chrome will
eventually be able to be
hardware accelerated
because of that same work.
It is very difficult to get off
the ground with a new system
like this, but it is off.
AUDIENCE: Hi, So this is -- is
it for oscillating to the
composition of the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in this level of the
-- in this topic?
Are you guys working to
accelerate 2D graphics,
let's say, like to
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
like the Internet
Explorer 9 is doing?
ERIK KAY: Yeah, we're also
working to accelerate
2D graphics as well.
AUDIENCE: And are you guys
planning on doing any work with
the Audio Tag, like the work
that the Mozilla
guys are doing?
ALEX RUSSELL: We
support it, yes.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
Yeah, but to be able to send
it to the buffer, you know,
get the data to the--
ALEX RUSSELL: Do you
mean the Mozilla--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
ALEX RUSSELL: --the extensions
is the idea that Mozilla
has offered so far.
IAN FETTE: So I'm not sure
about the Mozilla extensions
to the Audio Tag.
We are working on another audio
API that will actually grant
you positional audio
capabilities.
So this is an API where you
cannot just construct audio on
the fly, but you can also
control effects such as
position, directionality,
reverb, the whole sort of line
of audio controls that you'd
expect from something like
DirectX, Audio API, that level
of capability we're looking to
expose in the browser, and that
work is happening in WebKit.
There's a specification being
worked on by one of the
engineers at Google for that.
So we are taking
audio seriously.
I unfortunately am not familiar
with the exact extensions
to the Audio Tag that
you're referencing.
But I can tell you that we do
take very seriously the
requirement to be able to build
up audio on the fly as well
as control things
like positioning.
So not just playing back a
simple audio file, but actually
generating an audio stream on
the fly and controlling the
position of that audio.
AUDIENCE: And also, do you
think you guys have reached
the limits of the canvas tag?
Like the speed that you're
drawing stuff, or, you know,
you know, that you draw
pixels and on geometry?
IAN FETTE: The question is have
we reached the limits of the
canvas tag in terms of speed?
ALEX RUSSELL: I think, no.
IAN FETTE: No.
ALEX RUSSELL: Very briefly, so
the canvas tag today uses a
single array exposed to
JavaScript that you script,
right, and then you
have drawn commands.
Some things are going to
continue to get faster.
So V8 is continuing to get
faster and we're excited about,
you know, how much faster it's
going to be in the future.
So that aspect of canvas
performance is going to
continue to improve.
There's also work happening
right now, both in part due to
some great proposals from
Mozilla around typed array,
which is a binary array
subtype, and that work has sort
of spilled over into the
TC39 the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
working group, and it's
being actively considered
sort of as we speak.
So a binary-array type in
JavaScript as a language will
help us sort of accelerate some
of those use cases as well.
So where that goes,
you can imagine.
I think there has been work
in the past in proposals on
mailing lists for moving canvas
processing on working threads.
So getting it off of the
main thread and maybe
onto a difference CPU.
That's exciting as well.
So there are other
opportunities for us to
accelerate it and sort of, you
know, as canvas performance
becomes a limiting factor, I
think you should expect to see
us exploring more of those.
ERIK KAY: By the way, one other
thing I want to mention about
performance, and we're
obviously very passionate about
making the processor faster in
all aspects, but some of the
newer features of the web don't
have a lot of use cases out
there yet, and so we don't
necessarily know where the
limits are and where
the problems are.
So what we always encourage
people to do is to don't just
assume that something is the
way it is and that
that's a limit.
If you see something that feels
slow, you know, file a bug.
Express it in the
form of a benchmark.
It turns out if you put a web
page out there that has a --
that'll spit out a number, you
know, that says your browser
runs this thing at -- with a
score of 42 and this other
browser runs a speed of 78--
IAN FETTE: We'll beat them.
ERIK KAY: Yeah,
we'll beat them.
ALEX RUSSELL: Well, you'd first
expect browser vendors to argue
over whether or not it's a
reasonable measurement.
But once they do, they'll also
at the same time be
accelerating that test case so
that they look good
on it as well.
ERIK KAY: Yeah, exactly.
So the thing that's interesting
is, if you have a web app and
your web app feels slow for
some reason, take your web
app and consolidate it
down to a benchmark.
Publish that, and you'll have
browser makers competing to
make your web app faster.
Trust me, it works.
AUDIENCE: So I work with a lot
of embedded and
resource-constrained hardware,
and it seems like there's a
potential for a lot of overlap
between Chrome OS and Android,
and I was wondering if someone
on your team can speak as to
which hardware maybe Chrome OS
is more targeted towards
versus Android?
BRIAN RAKOWSKI: Yeah,
I can answer that.
You know, right now, the
Android team is focused on
handsets, the Chrome team is
focused on small form-factor
laptops, netbooks.
It's easy to see that there's
some place where those two
things converge, just looking
at the trends and looking at
iPads and things like that.
And, of course, the next
question is, well, which one of
these things is gonna run
better on those devices, where
it's like a touchscreen so it
kinda seems like Android, but
it's a little bit bigger so it
kinda seems like Chrome and you
want a more powerful browser,
and I think the truth and the
answer there is we don't know.
We have two open-source
solutions out there trying to
be the best solution for,
popular use cases today, and I
think both of us will explore,
you know, how far we can take
those different approaches.
Both of them have
their pros and cons.
Both of them have the
different targets right now.
But we'll see.
We don't know, and I think
that's a good thing.
We'll have to see
which one pans out.
We'll have to see which ends up
supporting those use cases.
We'll have to see which of
these devices ends up being
popular with consumers and
important for us to nail.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I know we talk
a lot about performance in
Chrome and V8 is just
incredibly quick.
I've been pretty thrilled with
that in my web application, but
with that continuing to
improve, what you think is the
future of the native code
execution in a browser that
also is being developed
here at Google?
IAN FETTE: So I think that
native code execution is
important for two things.
One is raw performance and
speed, and I think that we are
going to continue to increase
that performance of V8 to give
the faster JavaScript, but
there will eventually come a
point where you hit a level,
you know, where as a language,
JavaScript is not going to be
as fast for certain types of
operations as native
code would be.
So I think that there's
certainly a use case for
native code for certain
types of operations.
For instance, every time you
want to access a JavaScript
object in V8, you're gonna have
to make sure is this object
still the same, is this
function still valid for this
object, does it have the same
address, that's going
to add some overhead.
So native code where it's
compiled in advance will
have an advantage there.
But I think one of the other
big advantages for native
client is not just in terms of
performance, but realizing that
there is this huge wealth of
already existing code in the
wild that is not JavaScript.
So if you look at games, for
instance, there are years and
years that have been spent
developing things like
physics libraries and graph
extensions for games.
These are -- these would be
very difficult and time
intensive to port over to
JavaScript, but if you could
compile them and run them and
see in, the browser you'd be
able to immediately take all
of that work and port your
application to the browser.
So something like a game
that had been written
for iPhone in C
or Objective-C could
potentially, if you have
support for those libraries
and for native code -- could
potentially be run in a
browser with a minimal
amount of effort.
So I think that that's another
advantage to approaches
like native client.
It's not just about
performance.
Performance is a huge benefit,
but you also get the benefit of
being able to take advantage
of existing code bases.
ALEX RUSSELL: And maybe a
different framing is to
think of it in terms of
effort versus outcome.
And if you can't run native
code, there's a cap on what
sort of outcomes you can
achieve per some level
of effort, right?
And so that transition, that
transition point from I can do
some simple HTML and I can
start scripting it with
JavaScript, you know, if you're
gonna hit this thing up here
where you can't sort of deliver
that rich sort of game-like 3D
world experience, which just
doesn't have a semantic meaning
as a document, you
need to go, right?
You need to keep going
and the web needs to
deliver that to you.
And so we think of our job as
browser vendors as giving you
full access to the platform in
a way that's useful, easy, safe
and scales with your effort.
ERIK KAY: By the way, just
one other follow-on, we've
mentioned this a few times, but
I think it's worth sort of
combining it a bit is we've
referenced that something
will be useful for games.
And the reason we keep bringing
that up is because we think
it's an important thing to
really enable, to enable
full-fidelity entertainment,
you know, via the web.
And so that means
audio, video, 3D.
That means high-performance.
That means dealing with
existing co-libraries.
It means providing people a
means to monetize, to sell
these -- these games where
maybe advertising
might not work.
These are all things that we
think, you know, are connected.
AUDIENCE: For people that might
want to aspire to be on a
Google Chrome development team
in the future, what experience
or how did you guys end
up being on this team?
IAN FETTE: I got a
call from that guy.
BRIAN RAKOWSKI: Yeah, so
there's a bunch of different
skill sets that we
look for on the team.
We have -- on this panel we
have representing people who
are engineers and also
product managers.
Ian came to us because we were
looking for somebody who
understood security
very deeply.
He was doing some work -- he
was working on a PhD and we
stole him out of his PhD
program because we needed
a security expert on the
team to fill the PM role.
So if you know a lot about web
technology, that's pretty good.
If you know a lot about
browsers, that's pretty good.
The engineering -- maybe
you guys want to talk
about engineering.
ERIK KAY: Yeah, the engineering
philosophy -- I mean, there's a
lot to read out on the net so I
won't talk about it too, too
much here, but the general
Google hiring philosophy
applies to Chrome, which is
that we do like to higher
generalists, people who, you
know, can do a lot, who can
wear a lot of hats, can see the
big picture, and who aren't
afraid to dive into code
at, you know, at any
level of the system.
So that seems to be a
guiding principle.
There's a lot of stuff about
challenging interview questions
and being able to answer, you
know, complex coding things,
but really if you're, you know,
a good overall engineer,
can code in C
-- unfortunately, that's what
we're coding in for Chrome
-- that's a good start.
One other thing that just the
Chrome -- you have an advantage
if you're interested in getting
on the Chrome team versus just
becoming a generic Google
engineer is that it's an
open-source project.
And we really love
external contributors.
You know, it's not often that
you get people volunteering to
help you do your job, and it's
really humbling, actually, that
we've created something that
people are passionate about and
really want to get
involved with.
Back when I went to college,
you know, open source was just
getting going and there weren't
as many opportunities, and what
I'd recommend any aspiring, you
know, developer to do is jump
on an open-source project.
You know, yeah, you're not
getting paid for it, but, you
know, this is great experience.
And we welcome contributions.
There's a guide about how to
get started, how to build it.
There's even a set of bugs
that we have tagged that say
"help wanted" or
"good starter bug,"
you know, that are good
places to get going.
So if you really are aspiring
and interested in building and
getting involved in Chrome, we
have hired people who came on
as contributors to the project,
and I'll tell you, there is no
better interview than the proof
that you actually contributed
code and can have people on
the team vouch for you.
ALEX RUSSELL: This isn't
unique to Chrome, by the way.
I've worked at lots of other
the companies where if you
could walk in and say I'm a
committer at Apache, that buys
you -- you know, all the
interviews before lunch
are sort of cut off.
It's not true at Google, but
generally speaking, if you're
looking for advice in terms of
how to get hired anywhere, I
would suggest that you find
something you really care about
and go work on it in an
open-source project.
BRIAN RAKOWSKI: By the
way, is Muhammad here?
I know he came out for IO.
He may not be in this session,
but one of our open-source
committers came out and
he visited the office.
I think it was yesterday
he was walking around.
So it was nice to
meet him in person.
There's a lot of people out
there who we communicate
with on a daily basis who
we've never seen so--
ERIK KAY: Sure, and by the way,
from all around the world.
One of our most prolific and
early open-source contributors
was from Poland, and even
though he's working on his PhD,
he contributes tremendously,
you know, even in
his spare time.
So there's a lot
of opportunity.
IAN FETTE: And it's worth
pointing out that we do have
offices all around the world,
not just in California, but
all the way out to London,
Tokyo and Russia as well.
BRIAN RAKOWSKI: I guess the
point is that we need help.
We have way too
much stuff to do.
Please help.
ALEX RUSSELL: There's no part
of computer science aside,
I think, from artificial
intelligence and large-scale
intelligence that we don't
touch as the Chrome team.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have
two questions.
The first one is we've done a
lot of benchmarking between the
browser on Android and Chrome
browser like SunSpider, V8
benchmark, and I'm talking
about the Android Eclair
release, and it's significantly
slower than Chrome.
So can you comment on whether,
you know, Chrome can run on
Android or whether there would
be plans, and how you
plan to fix the gap?
ERIK KAY: So none of us are on
the Android team, but we do
talk to them, and we do a share
a lot back and forth, so take
what I say with a little
bit of a grain of salt.
We share a lot of resources
between -- in code.
Android -- and we
both use WebKit.
Android is now, I think with
Froyo started to use V8 and
also using Chrome's
network stack.
So we're sharing more
and more each day.
and I think that you're gonna
see that their performance and
ours, you know, get closer
and closer over time.
So in the browser front, we
do collaborate quite a bit.
And I think, as Ian was
saying earlier, we do have
different constraints.
You know, on the desktop, we've
got, you know, we can pretty
much assume, you know, people
have a lot of memory,
a lot of RAM.
But, you know, on Android
devices, you can't.
It's a much smaller
footprint, in general.
The other thing that you've got
that's a problem on Android
that people don't really
realize is that actually
the Flash storage is
quite high latency.
People think of Flash as being
faster, but it turns out that
writing to Flash, especially
the type of Flash that's
in phones is pretty slow.
And so you have to be careful
about how often you write, so
even simple things like dealing
with cookies -- I know the
engineer who worked on the
cookie system for Android and
she was complaining to me about
how, trying to, you know, write
to the database, these cookie
changes was killing
their performance.
This was a long time ago.
They've fixed some of that.
But it was -- they had to come
up with tricks and ways to
avoid having to write too much.
So we're always going to be a
bit different, just due to the
constraints and the types of
hardware that we're running on,
and it's not really fair to do
a strict apples-to-apples
comparison there, but
conceptually, assume that
they're getting closer
and closer over time.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
The second question is can you
comment more on the video
standards for what Chrome
browser would be using now
that VP8 is being announced?
You know, which do you think
would be more standard?
H.264 or VP8, and how
does Flash play into it?
IAN FETTE: So we did announce
this morning in the keynote
support for WebM, which is
the VP8 plus Ogg Vorbis.
It's the audio in basically
a Matroska container.
We're obviously going
to support WebM.
We're already supporting
H.264 as well as Ogg Theora.
I think that right now it's a
bit early to say whether we're
going to make any changes in
terms of discontinuing support
for anything that we're
currently shipping.
I think right now we're putting
a lot of focus into making sure
that WebM is performant in
Chrome and that we get hardware
support for WebM and we're
trying to make sure that
that's a great experience.
And once we have more
experience, more data on how
that goes and what the adoption
is, at that point we'll look to
see up what we're going to do
with respect to the
other codecs that we're
currently shipping.
AUDIENCE: Why is it unfortunate
that you guys use C plus plus?
ALEX RUSSELL: Oh, it's not.
I was joking.
00:42:52,11 --> 00:42:52,044
AUDIENCE: Oh,
really?
ALEX RUSSELL: It's fast.
And we need Chrome to be fast.
Speed is what we're going
for at every point.
On the other hand, C
is a very large language.
It's difficult to
know all of it.
So there's a very high
bar to getting going
and getting started.
I didn't mean that as a
slight to C plus plus.
But if you're a -- if you're a
wizard at Valgrind and you love
finding memory bugs, definitely
go to Google dot
com slash jobs.
ERIK KAY: Yeah, I think that's
the biggest thing is that C
is -- we wouldn't have
chosen anything different
even in retrospect.
It's the right
tool for the job.
However, with great power
comes great responsibility,
as they say.
It's, you know, it's a
dangerous language and
so, as a result, we have
to be very careful.
Very early on, we used Purify
pretty heavily because we were
deeply paranoid about the kind
of bugs we know were
going to happen.
Once Linux and Mac came online,
getting Valgrind, we helped
sponsor the Valgrind Mac port
because we really, really
wanted to make sure that we
weren't introducing
new memory bugs.
This is an area that I
think if you're doing C
development, C development,
you cannot be too paranoid
about this in your
development process.
And building it into your tools
and into your build process
is an important thing to do.
ALEX RUSSELL: It's also in
the architecture with the
sandbox model, right?
That paranoia goes
all the way down.
AUDIENCE: Just how is it as
developers, being somebody
that's pushing standards, you
guys are getting everyone to
join the bandwagon, and then
you've got people lagging
behind like Internet Explorer
and how -- as developers, you
know, we'll love to develop on
and push all the stuff, but
then we also have to support
like the weak chain.
IAN FETTE: I would actually
turn that question around and
ask, as an application
developer, not as a browser
developer, what's it like to
have certain browsers that are
lagging behind and what can
I do as an application
developer to change that?
AUDIENCE: It's
definitely something.
Like how do we -- what can
we do to help you guys?
IAN FETTE: Build better apps.
Like, I'm not kidding.
The best way to do it is
to build apps that are
absolutely awesome.
Get them to work great.
Show that these --
functionalities that you want
to take advantage of can
actually let you do awesome
things, and if you have a huge
app with a huge number of
users, I don't work for
Microsoft, so I can't say I
guarantee it, but I would
expect that if you build
it, they will come.
ALEX RUSSELL: So I work on
Chrome Frame, which for those
of you who may not be familiar
with it is a plug-in for
Internet Explorer that
puts Chrome's rendering
engine inside of IE.
I feel your pain, right?
I think that's the
easiest way to say it.
I worked on a Javascript
library before I came to
join Google, and that
was sort of Plan B.
Plan A was browser competition
gets us new features
everywhere faster.
Browser competition
should always be Plan A.
Part of the reason that specs
work so well is that they get
every other browser vendor on
the exact same page that we
are, and hopefull, it
happens very quickly.
We work on something, we look,
we build a spec where we
contribute to a spec, we find a
spec that already does what we
want, and we implement it.
And then hopefully, everyone
else comes along very quickly.
There's a sum chunk of the user
base who may not be making
informed choices about their
usage of browsers, and so I
acknowledge that we have an
economic problem here where we
have to bring many users along
who you may not know that they
have choices and may not
know how to exercise
them if they do.
So Chrome Frame is our sort
of interstitial answer here.
We need a way to help
organizations and users come
along for the ride, get the new
applications where they may not
be able to make choices
about getting a different
browser for themselves.
But hopefully, that's a way
station on the way to getting
people to use better browsers
in general and getting people
to have browsers that
auto-update, right?
One of the best things -- one
of the most wonderful things
I've seen in a very long time
was watching the browser
percentages over the summer of
2009 when Microsoft turned the
auto-update switch for IE7 to
IE8 on as a high-priority
update to XP and Vista.
You could watch the percentages
flip in a matter of months.
This is really good news.
This is good stuff.
That means that auto-update
works and that browser
competition works.
We get great new features and
we get them faster when we have
browsers that auto-update --
ERIK KAY: By the way, I think
that you've asked the question
that is almost by definition
the reason for Chrome's
existence, which is that
browser development wasn't
happening fast enough and
standards weren't moving
fast enough and performance
wasn't moving fast enough.
These were things that
were not good enough.
And so part of the whole
purpose of Chrome's existence
was to light a fire for the
whole industry, and I hope that
people, you know, that see that
-- it seems like that that's
happening, and we're not done.
We think that the fact that if
you watch like, for example,
just the performance graph of
V8, you know, from when we came
out to where we're at now, the
Delta between version, you
know, Chrome 4 and Chrome 5
was, you know, as big or bigger
than the performance from
the previous release.
And basically, meanwhile, all
the other browsers makers are
slowly catching up, and we
don't want them to think, OK,
now I've gotten as good as
Chrome, I'm good enough.
Because we want to be at
that next level higher to
keep pushing it forward.
And so this is going to be on
performance, this is going
to be on standards and
capabilities and features and
on any axis that we can think
of to make browsers better.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE QUESTION]
So when a bug comes in --
sorry, question was, what's
our stance on security?
What happens when a
security bug comes in?
There's a number of ways that
security bugs are reported.
There's either the bug
tracker where you can file
a bug as a security bug.
We also get reports to Security
at Chromium dot org and
Security at Google dot com.
When those come in, a number of
people, myself included, get
emailed as a very high-priority
email to go take a look at that
bug to see a) is it valid, b)
can we reproduce it, c) how
serious is it, and we then go
about trying to understand the
bug, making sure that we can
reproduce it, if we can
reproduce it, understanding is
this something that
is exploitable?
If so, how exploitable?
Does it just crash the browser?
Does it let you execute
arbitrary code on
the user's computer?
If so, does that code
execute within the sandbox?
Does it execute outside
of the sandbox?
So we very rapidly
understand the bug and
the severity of the bug.
We then develop an update and
because of the auto-update
mechanism, we can push it out
-- we can push it out to all
of our users automatically.
You might not see it
immediately disclosed.
There's good reasons for that.
One of them is just the
delay in updating.
We don't update overnight.
We do sort of do a staged
update over a few days to make
sure that we're not going
to blow anything up.
But another reason is that a
lot of times we find bugs
in shared components.
This could be in the WebKit
code that we use for rendering.
It could be in a library that's
used by not just Chrome
but other applications.
So we want to make sure that
we're responsible with that
information, that we report
those bugs upstream and give
other users of that code a
chance to update their
applications as well before
we just open that bug
up to the public.
So we are very careful about
making sure that we update as
quickly as we can, but we also
want to do that disclosure of
the security bug in a
responsible manner.
So we're not trying to hide
the fact that we had a bug.
We're not trying to not
disclose it so that we
look better in some
bug timing metric.
It's really about doing the
right thing in making sure
that we aren't putting any
additional users at risk.
ERIK KAY: So another related
point I'd make is we're not
just reactive on the
security front.
We're not just waiting
for bugs to get reported
and then fix it.
We have a team of some of the
smartest security vulnerability
generators that I've ever seen.
These are the sort of people
that are really good at finding
exploits and things, and their
frightening, I mean, some of
the bug reports, it's,
you know, bizarre.
ALEX RUSSELL: Once you
understand it, it
actually does hurt.
ERIK KAY: So we have these
people who are actively trying
to break Chrome all the time
and, you know, on the payroll,
trying to do things, and one of
the things that I think that we
do that I'm very happy about
the way we do it is that when
they find bugs, we disclose
those bugs as well.
The fact that they were
discovered internally doesn't
mean it wasn't a bug.
It doesn't mean it's something
that we should be able
to really hide or
obscure from people.
So we'll publish that as well
when we fix that and let people
know that there was a bug in a
previous version, we tracked it
down and whatever, so you
can see those things.
BRIAN RAKOWSKI: We also
have a bug bounty program.
So if you find security bugs,
we want to reward people for
disclosing them responsibly,
and we'll give a little cash
to the people who do that
and give them a little
acknowledgment too.
Hopefully, that's inspiring
people and encouraging
people to do the right
thing with bugs.
AUDIENCE: Is the development of
the Go language in any way to
go help deal with the problems
encountered with memory issues
that have been discovered
by your team?
ALEX RUSSELL: It doesn't help
us, but I'm hopeful that the
browsers that come after us
could use something like Go.
IAN FETTE: So one thing that I
will say is when we created
Google Chrome and we decided
what rendering engine to use,
it was very important for us
not to create another
rendering engine.
We didn't want to -- and this
is not to say there should
never be another rendering
engine, but when we looked at
our options, we felt that if we
created another rendering
engine with a different set of
compatibility issues at that
time, it would not be a good
thing either for us or for
developers, so we were very
keen to use an existing
rendering engine, which also
heavily influences the
choice of language that
you're going to use.
Because if your browser and
engine action are in two
different languages, you
will have some fun.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned a few
times about your development
process, working on an
open-source project, dealing
with external contributors,
staying with the trunk.
Can you comment on how that
compares with the closed
projects within Google?
Is it roughly the same with the
apps guys or the mail guys?
IAN FETTE: I think
parts are the same and
parts are different.
Google has a very strong
culture around things like code
coverage and automated testing.
So a lot of --
ALEX RUSSELL: And code reviews.
IAN FETTE: And code reviews.
So a lot of projects in Google
share that philosophy of making
sure that there is something
like a continuous build so that
when you check in a change, you
can see did that -- did that
change break the build, did I
just hamper the productivity
of other developers?
But there are some unique
constraints that we face in a
open-source project, especially
when we're developing things
like the Chrome web store.
Obviously when you start
checking in changes like that,
not everyone's going to see.
So I think there's some.
There's a lot of shared culture
between the Chrome team and the
rest of Google in terms of
common engineering practices,
code review, automated testing,
but I think we also face some
slightly different constraints.
ERIK KAY: Yeah, I mean, the
project originated, you know,
at Google so I would say that
more that we -- that the code
team was influenced by Google's
existing engineering practices
rather than, you know, the
other way around, right?
So the code coverage, the
testing, even the frequent
release process I think is in
part a reflection of the fact
that Google is mostly
a web company, right?
Mostly used to this being able
to push, you know, right away,
you know, this week, you know,
as opposed to being on
monolithic yearly release
cycles, and that we
wanted to do that too.
And so I think the underlying
culture at Google definitely
influenced how we wanted to do
it even though we were going to
be open sourced, and that was
going to make us
a bit different.
IAN FETTE: Any other questions?
00:55:51,038 --> 00:55:51,018
Yes?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE QUESTION]
ALEX RUSSELL: I can take
a quick shot at it.
Oh, yes, of course.
So the question was we have a
challenge because we have so
many different dependencies
and we're adding new
features all the time.
So how do we manage the source
control between the trunk
version, which we released the
Dev channel off of, the Beta
channel, which is sort of like
the broader update, you know,
it's-probably-no
t-going-to-be-on-fire version,
and then the Stable channel,
which is it's definitely
not on fire.
So we have a couple of other
axes which are important.
First we have
external web bases.
So we work very closely
with the WebKit community.
And that means that we try to
stay as close to the WebKit tip
of trunk as possible, but if we
have to land a patch on both
sides, we have to commit it in
both places and keep
those in sync.
We use external libraries,
things like Skia, which
is our drawing library
on Windows and Linux.
Skia is the graphics library
that is also shared by Android.
And that component is also
a third-party component.
And we've actually taken that
opportunity to break out some
other components as well and
turn them into third-party
dependencies with their own
sort of Google code sites and
their own source control
systems and their own
revision systems.
So we have a lot of
dependencies in a lot of
places and some complexity
about rolling revisions.
So we built some tools.
I mean, that's sort of like, I
think, the Google engineer way
to do things is you go and you
build tools to make it happen.
So instead of having just raw
subversion, we have raw
subversion with a wrapper
called GClient and GCL.
GCL manages change lists and
GClient helps us sink revisions
to third-party dependencies so
that we can check in a file
sort of like subversion
externals that allows us to
lock to a particular
revision of an upstream or
third-party package.
And so when we say we want to
get a new version of WebKit, we
change the revision number of
that third-party upstream
dependency in the DEPS file.
We call it a DEPS roll.
And then we run it through
the continuous builds and
then everybody gets it.
So that's sort of the general
process is that we manage those
dependencies by sort of keeping
at a little bit of
an arm's length.
We're trying to stay up as
quickly as possible with them.
In terms of how we make
releases, there are branches.
There are two branches, usually
alive at any point in time.
There's the Dev channel,
which is trunk.
There's the Beta channel branch
and the release table branch.
And we selectively roll patches
in from trunk down to those two
branches so that they turn
much less frequently
than trunk does.
Does that answer the question?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE ANSWER]
ALEX RUSSELL: Great, yeah.
ERIK KAY: One additional
follow-on I'll say is that
the core part of our
release is the Dev channel.
So Beta and Stable are
really just patches, mostly
security bugs, little
incremental bug fixes.
The philosophy, the way
we describe it, is
called trunk stable.
So what it means is that the
trunk of our source repository
should always be buildable,
should always be in a reliable,
usable, shippable state
at any moment in time.
Now, we're not perfect about
that, but we're pretty
close, actually.
And so what that means to be
trunk stable, it puts a bit
more onus on each developer
with each check-in to think
about how your check-in is
going to keep it stable.
So, for example, when Ben
Goodger, UI lead, you know,
landed a -- wanted to redesign
how the tab system worked, the
underlying drawing and user
interaction mechanism, you can
imagine that that was going to
be a pretty destabilizing
change, and it's pretty hard
to land that in a
trunk-stable way.
But the way he did it was to
essentially have to land a
completely separate fork of
code that duplicated much of
the logic that was
in the other one.
So have two separate versions
of the code simultaneously in
the tree that were controlled
via a command line switch.
So basically, you land
the new feature and
it's behind of switch.
By default, you get
the old behavior.
If you use the switch, you
get the new behavior.
As you iterate, the new feature
gets more and more stable.
You start to feel
better about it.
At some point, you flip
the switch the other way.
So you still have a switch, but
it now is give me the old
behavior, please, type of
switch because you
broke something.
But the -- but you're trusting
it to be stable enough.
But because you've got
them still both in there,
it's easy to revert.
It's easy to say oops,
I broke something.
Let me quick switch it back
for a few revisions while
I fix it some more.
Now we'll try it again.
And so it's more work for us as
developers, but in the end,
it's actually a huge net
productivity gain because if
you've ever worked on projects
that are not -- don't have the
trunk-stable philosophy, you
get into a state where
people can't build.
You know, where the tree is
broken for long stretches of
time, where regressions creep
in and no one knows where they
started, and trying to track
those down becomes a nightmare.
Or you work on large feature
branches for months at a time
that suddenly land in one
gigantic merge, and that
suddenly destabilizes
everything.
So while it's more work for
each individual patch, the
net effect is a big win.
IAN FETTE: So I see our
clock in the back has
actually hit zero.
I'm supposing that means we are
probably out of time, so I'd
like to take this opportunity
to thank everyone in the
audience for coming, in asking
a great set of questions.
Thank you all so much.
It's great to get
this feedback.
And I hope you enjoy the rest
of your time here at Google IO.
And we'll probably be out in
the hall for a little bit if
you have any other questions
that you want to ask Thanks.